[تصفيق]
إذا كنت تأمل في عام جديد أكثر صحة ،
فقد تجد الدافع بالقرب من
المنزل ، والسماح لحيواناتنا الأليفة تساعدنا في الحصول على
صحة جيدة هي طريقة رائعة للذهاب إلى تيما
مارتن مع أفضل الأصدقاء ، يقول مجتمع الحيوانات
إذا كان هدفك هو الانتقال إلى
2022 يمكن أن يساعدك صديقك ذي الفراء في
الحصول على كلب يعرف ما يعنيه
عندما ترتدي حذاء المشي الخاص
بك أو حذاء الجري الخاص بك ، سوف يجلبون
لك مقودهم الذي يريدون الخروج منه
وممارسة الرياضة أيضًا ، وقد ترغب بعض القطط في
التنزه  ويمكن أن تساعد حيواناتك أيضًا في
تقليل التوتر حتى أن مجرد الاتصال بالعين
مع كلابنا وقططنا يتمتع بصحة جيدة لأن
أولئك الذين
تعرفهم يثيرون شعورًا بالحب
والراحة لنا وإذا كان هدفك هو
تناول الكثير من الفواكه والخضروات بشكل أفضل مثل
التفاح والجزر الصغير.  من الآمن
أن يستمتع كلبك أيضًا بإجراء بعض
الأبحاث لمعرفة نوع
الوجبات الخفيفة الصحية التي يمكنك
تناولها لنفسك ومشاركتها مع حيوانك الأليف والتي ستكون
طريقة رائعة للحفاظ على قرارك للعام الجديد
للبقاء بصحة جيدة على مدار
الدورة التدريبية.  إذا شعر الكثيرون بالوباء
بالعزلة ، لكن تمشية حيوانك الأليف يمكن أن
تجعلك تعيش في الهواء الطلق وتتيح لك أن تكون
اجتماعيًا مع الآخرين على مسافة ، وقد
يساعد أيضًا في الصحة العقلية بالإضافة إلى السماح
لك بتذكر الأشياء الجيدة في
حياتك.  وقت رائع للتوقف
والتركيز على مقدار ما تعطيه حيواناتنا الأليفة
لنا مقابل دقيقة صحية أنا ماندي غايثر